hey I'm here with Andy Kindler one of my
favorite comedians and a guy that I've
been relentlessly harassing on Twitter
so this is proof people that if you
harass people on Twitter enough you may
just end up at a table exactly with
cameras right they're pretty good and
but least I followed you and you follow
me because the one the most annoying
thing is hey follow me when people say
that it was very far as each other
because I I liked what you were I like
the cut of your jib and so I followed
you so then when you then you start the
direct message hassling that was
probably eight to ten times a day no no
I mean actually you did the right thing
because if you don't aren't persistent
with me I will forget everything yeah
even what we're talking about yeah this
is not me I'm a comedian I would not
wouldn't say that was my best material
but it was a good opening salvo yeah all
right so you you are not only a comedian
but you're really like the comics comic
you you do the Just for Laughs state of
the industry thing this is where you get
to basically rip every comedian there is
and talk about the guys you like but
really you get to roast this crazy
business that were and how did you end
up doing that because I think it's sort
of every comics dream actually well I
don't know if it's every kind of strict
well yeah because I think a lot of
comics and I've always think I thought
it was odd you know like comics even
they're just like off stage or whenever
will say to me or they have a rule you
don't make a lot of other comics in
other words you can do 80,000 Michael
Jackson jokes in a row or make fun of
any celeb am not saying that's a good
current bit but it makes fun of any
celebrity but there's some kind of
unwritten rules so I broke that rule and
I always was fascinated with what's
wrong my god with TV and comedy so what
I went to the I've been going to the
Just for Laughs festival for like 20
years and it just happened to work out
that way and I did this speech one year
about I wrote an article for National
Lampoon about how to be a hack comic
which is still on my website and you
Kindler calm read none of the above
that's what you click on and if you want
to see my tour dates from the early
2000s they're still up but so I did a
demonstration up there Montreal and then
they said would you come back the next
year and do something else and my
manager came up with state of the
industry so for I think
17 years I'm kind of roasting the the
industry and sometimes it was started
out just a lot of anger then I got it to
more like a roast in the last couple of
years I've gotten more that's serious
about it but I've got after people that
has caused more of a stir but not
because I'm trying to make a name for
myself with it right so this year you
went after Adam Carolla I am NOT a big
fan of by any stretch and he's gone that
weird Dennis Miller route where he
suddenly is like an O'Reilly favorite
but how conscious are you that whatever
you say about him is suddenly gonna be
blown up into this comedy war because
everyone in the comedy world loves a
good comedy war well the thing that
really bothered me about this well first
of all I I find Dennis Miller detestable
what do you prefer his references well
because he doesn't even do jokes anymore
they're all like oh this guy's like the
cosmic cop from crime and punishment
back in the Middle Ages with the problem
I think there's no jokes it's just a
construction but at least he says he's
on a horrible right wing the answer he
so you know what you're getting right
you're gonna get a guy who's something
happened to him after to 2001 9/11 and
he's changed into this and he was always
kind of a nasty guy anyway but he was a
funny comedian
whereas Corolla is doing a thing that I
think is just really kind of disgusting
because he's saying he's a comedian but
he's not a comedian I mean nothing he's
never been funny I never watched love
lines some people like them and I guess
he could be chart whatever the things
but he's gotta stand up he's a stand
well that's the other thing is he's now
touring or making a movie about stand-up
and the guy the guy never did stand that
we just started doing stand-up but he's
basically saying racist things under the
guise of being a comedian and but we
really bothered me was the reporting on
it I get back to LA and so and as this
guy writes an article Kindler cuss calls
a Corolla an unfunny Hitler doesn't seem
to be kidding and that bothered me
because I am III didn't invent Hitler
jokes but I've been using it forever so
that was it I said that corals like
Hitler if Hitler wasn't funny
all right so now that's an absurd
comment but that's the thing I never had
to deal with in the past is just people
just reporting on it yeah so that's the
part that I think is fast
it's one thing for all of us you know
comedians can behind-the-scenes talk
about each other and oh you know this
guy's a hack and that has a hat but now
everything you put out there it gets
written about in in Slate or its
attacked by twitchy on Twitter and all
that is that does that stuff bother you
yeah well as twitchy calm is just a
hate-mongering site and so you know I'm
tweeting things first of all I will say
like if I tweet something like the GOP
we're not you know we're not your
father's racists you know we're more
like your grandfather's racist that's a
that is a joke I do believe though but
the point is serious the GOP as a party
is racist and if you don't believe if
you're gonna really argue that North
Carolina is about first of all I don't
even think there should be idea that to
vote if you had nobody had ID when they
voted do you know how much fraud that
would be little to none people did not
steal elections by sending imposters
down to the polling place
oh I'm sorry Andy Kindler there was
another Andy Kindler here that's not how
you steal elections so it's a problem
that doesn't exist and the GOP is using
racism that they've always done but now
that they've got these troops of like
goons like twitchy calm - just like they
just start attacking me and I have I
have to block them
it's a nightmare with the block with the
block and also the mist report and
people who didn't even hear the speech
like on this PJ something yeah the
people who haven't even seen it and that
to me is really upsets me that you
haven't seen it and you're gonna
characterize it and the hell with them
yeah and of course it's always taken out
of context and every time you tweet
anything right they make it seem like
you're some sort of hardcore political
pundit instead of I do belong to you and
people write to me look oh you mean if
I'm a Republican I said no did I say
Republicans I said the party is
organized around this principle yeah
okay so then just interact it stop
talking oh my god I'm gonna report this
too twitchy all right so two quick last
things so one of the things that I
really genuinely admire about you is
that you put this stuff out there and
unapologetically and you get from
the industry and all that and I I'm
trying to do the same thing I like to
think I'm doing the same thing how much
do you get concerned that it will affect
your career or your ability to be cast
with
people in the future because one day
Leno could have some somebody could say
you know Leto maybe you should work with
yeah well that would never happen
neither answer he's not gonna work with
me either
oh yeah the thing is I have a general
joke about this is which is like look
I'm already I'm sure I've lost a lot of
work from being outspoken so what's
gonna happen the people who aren't using
me are gonna not call me more yeah I
mean so it's like I worry because I'm I
worry for like things like I don't you
know I don't want Adam coral to punch me
in the face or one of his goons to punch
me in the face so but those are like
small concerns to me I mean I'm I don't
want to get hurt I don't want to
confront the people so I'm more worried
about about some crazy person hit him
well he I don't think he is crazy but
it's more like that that physical though
I'm not worried about my career because
my career that ship has sailed
you know I'm saying yeah it's like my
the name of my career should be one
direction am i right
who's wind me flat is that part of it
though really though that when you took
this turn in your career you had already
may had a certain amount of success so
it was a little safer then sort of maybe
some unknown guy getting out there and
attacking everybody you know what I mean
like you had had enough success we're
sort of to be okay in the long I think
but not really because as you know this
business is like every three years
you're broke so I don't think I never
felt it was more like I was compelled to
do it
and the thing that bothers me when
people think that I'm saying things
about Corolla or whatever to know to
pump my it's a big thing on Twitter it's
what have you done you're and you're
nobody like this is so ridiculous but
it's more like I'm compelled to do it
and I think I but also I've you know
carved out a niche so it's kind of cool
because people like that I do it and I
don't do it for that reason so it's like
as many people as I've alienated I've
also attracted and these days to I think
it's getting better more easy to you
know through Twitter and stuff to get
your own you know quote following yeah
alright so a last question which is if
you weren't a comedian what in God's
name would you be doing on this planet
well before I was a comedian I was a
singer songwriter guitarist and that's
what I thought I was gonna do when I
graduated school I came out to Los
Angeles and I was only one of 47 million
the singer songwriter guitarist and I
was I stumbled in the comedy because
I every one of my family was funding I
took it for granted and I was trying to
make do music in bars and things like
that but my one that one turning point
my life was I was in a bar in the top 40
band and I was talking in between the
songs and the club owner passed up a
note and say cut the chatter so so music
music would be my next choice but then I
actually loved being bit and this is
gonna sound wrong but I love being a
waiter and I love being a bartender so I
always say to myself that job was pure
joy to me although drive some people
crazy so I think being a waiter would do
my next go to go to position Wow the
comedian that once I reach for the stars
the comedian that wants to be the waiter
I have never heard that one bartender
all right well I seriously I thank you
for sitting around for a couple extra
minutes and well yeah because the day is
jammed for me we'll keep doing this in
140 characters this was pretty good we
spoke in full sentences and this was
fantastic I don't have to you never said
one of three as you're talking